all right we have a lot to discuss this  is our fifth year this is our fifth year  of flashbacks for Oliver Stephen how's  your Russian coming along no it's  actually it's pretty good not it's not  bad we have a phonetics coach and a  translator on set when after you russian  and it seemed to be working it was great  in the first season that was all faking  for a season we're actually trying to do  it properly he's like this is actually  what you're saying this is the word that  you should emphasize etc etc and we're  trying to do it right I yeah 100th  episode party yeah all that stuff  good nice feels like like a mini  Renaissance we show it was really good  it was really good right now I had I had  dinner with Greg after the season and  you know Greg Blanche we talked a lot  about how some of his favorite shows you  know they like his favorite seasons we  like seasons 5 season 6 season 7 so I  feel like we're in a really good spot  right now I'm very very excited